TONIGHT.
TUCKER CARLSON COMING UP NEXT.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
RAHM EMANUEL MAY BE A DEMOCRAT
IN ONE OF THE MOST DEMOCRATIC
CITIES IN THE WORLD, BUT THAT
DOESN'T MEAN HE IS POPULAR
THERE.
THIS CITY OF CHICAGO WAS FALLING
APART IN A LOT OF WAYS, IT IS
DEEPLY IN DEBT, OVER 50 BILLION
IN DEBT.
650 MURDERS THERE LAST YEAR,
MOST OF THE SCHOOLS ARE
GENUINELY TERRIBLE.
HE WOULD NOT SIGN YOUR OWN KIDS
UNDER ANY CIRCUMSTANCES.
NOT SURPRISINGLY, POLLS OF
CHICAGO VOTERS FROM LAST YEAR
SHOWED RAHM EMANUEL'S APPROVAL
RATING AT ABOUT 25%, WITH
NUMBERS LIKE THAT, THERE IS NO
CHANCE HE WILL BE REELECTED NEXT
YEAR.
BUT LIKE A LOT OF UNPOPULAR
DEMOCRATS, BRAHMA MANUAL HAS A
PLAN TO KEEP HIMSELF IN POWER.
HE CAN'T WIN OVER EXISTING
VOTERS, AND HE HASN'T BEEN ABLE
TO.
HE CAN CREATE NEW ONES.
CHICAGO IS ROLLING OUT A NEW
GOVERNMENT I.D. CARD CALLED THE
CITY KEY.
A FEW MONTHS AGO, HE SAID IT WAS
SUPPOSED TO BRING ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS OUT OF THE SHADOWS.
THE CARDS DON'T STORE PERSONAL
INFORMATION, I.C.E. CAN'T USE
THEM TO ENFORCE FEDERAL LAW, AND
THAT IS INTENTIONAL.
CHICAGO HAS ANNOUNCED THAT THESE
CARDS, WHICH WERE DESIGNED FOR
ILLEGAL ALIENS, CAN BE USED FOR
VOTER REGISTRATION, IN OTHER
WORDS, NONCITIZEN ILLEGALS WILL
BE ABLE TO VOTE IN THE CITY OF
CHICAGO, INCLUDING IN FEDERAL
ELECTIONS THAT AFFECT YOU.
THAT IS ILLEGAL.
CONGRESS PASSED A LAW AGAINST
IT, IT'S EXPLICITLY ILLEGAL.
YET THE CITY IS ENCOURAGING IT.
WHEN A REPORTER ASKED THIS
ALDERMAN ABOUT THIS, HE DID NOT
CARE.
"THERE IS NOTHING STOPPING
SOMEONE FROM GETTING A FAKE I.D.
NOW AND GOING TO TRY TO VOTE, HE
SAID.
THAT IS TRUE, OF COURSE, BUT
THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN IGNORING
VOTER FRAUD, WHICH IS WRONG, AND
ABETTING IT, WHICH IS
HORRIFYING.
AUTHORITIES IN CHICAGO WANT
INELIGIBLE VOTERS TO VOTE.
WHY WOULD THEY WANT THAT?
AS THE "CHICAGO TRIBUNE" POINTED
OUT, IT'S PRETTY SIMPLE.
RAHM EMANUEL WANTS TO GET
REELECTED.
IF IT TAKES ILLEGAL TO DO SO,
FINE, WHATEVER IT TAKES.
WE CONTACTED THE MAYOR'S OFFICE
FOR CONTACT, AND IT DID NOT
BOTHER TO RESPOND.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT FOR SOME
REASON DOESN'T SEEM TO BE DOING
ANYTHING ABOUT ANY OF THIS.
IT IS NOT JUST HAPPENING IN THE
CITY OF CHICAGO.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA,
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS GOOD DRIVER'S
LICENSE, HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS
OF THEM, AND THEY CAN USE THOSE
TO REGISTER TO VOTE AND SOME DO.
IN THE STATE OF MARYLAND, SOME
TOWNS ARE TRYING TO LEGALIZE
VOTING FOR ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
HOW LONG UNTIL THAT IS A
DEMOCRATIC PARTY PLATFORM?
HOW LONG AT ALL SOME FEDERAL
JUDGE IN HAWAII DECLARES
THAT PREVENTING ILLEGAL ALIENS
FROM VOTING IS RACIST AND
DEMANDS THEY GET THE BOAT
IMMEDIATELY NATIONWIDE?
IT'S COMING, OF COURSE IT IS.
THE LEFT WANTS POWER, AND THIS
WILL GIVE IT TO THEM.
CHICAGO ALDERMAN SPONSORED THE
BILL CREATING THE IDs AND HE
JOINS US.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: DO YOU SUPPORT
NONCITIZENS VOTING?
>> I THINK THERE'S A
MISUNDERSTANDING ABOUT THE CITY
KEY IS.
AS A LIBRARY CARD, ACCESS TO THE
MASS TRANSIT, A MUNICIPAL
I.D. THAT GIVES PEOPLE WHO ARE
EXITING HOMELESSNESS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PREVENT AN I.D.
WHERE A DRIVER'S LICENSE OR
STATE I.D. MIGHT BE TOO
EXPENSIVE.
IT ALSO IS AVAILABLE TO OUR
UNDOCUMENTED NEIGHBORS.
BUT LET ME BE ALSO CLEAR.
IN ORDER FOR SOMEONE TO REGISTER
TO VOTE, THEY WOULD HAVE TO SIGN
AN AFFIDAVIT AND PRESENT A BIRTH
CERTIFICATE, A PASSPORT, A
SOCIAL SECURITY CARD, AND
POTENTIALLY, YOU'D STILL NEED A
SECOND FORM OF I.D.
AND IF YOU FRAUDULENTLY, IF YOU
DEFRAUD THE CHICAGO BOARD OF
ELECTIONS, THE ILLINOIS STATE
BOARD OF ELECTIONS, AND YOU ARE
UNDOCUMENTED, YOU ARE SUBJECT TO
DEPORTATION.
SO THIS IS NOT A MUNICIPAL I.D.
>> Tucker: I JUST WANT TO GET
THIS ON THE RECORD.
YOU ARE FACTUALLY INACCURATE.
I JUST WANT TO HEAR YOU SAY IT.
YOU ARE SAYING THAT IN ORDER TO
REGISTER TO VOTE, AND THE STATE
OF ILLINOIS, YOU NEED TO PRODUCE
EVIDENCE OF CITIZENSHIP.
IS THAT YOUR CLAIM?
>> YES, IT IS.
I ALSO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT WHAT YOU ARE
SUGGESTING IS THAT THE CITY OF
CHICAGO, THE ILLINOIS STATE
BOARD OF ELECTIONS, THE CHICAGO
BOARD OF ELECTIONS, AND
UNDOCUMENTED NEIGHBORS ARE ALL
COORDINATING WITH ONE ANOTHER.
>> Tucker: I'M NOT
SUGGESTING -- SLOW DOWN.
I'M NOT SUGGESTING A CONSPIRACY.
I WANT TO GET BACK TO MY
ORIGINAL QUESTION, DO YOU
SUPPORT NONCITIZENS VOTING?
I THINK IT'LL BE INTERESTING TO
HEAR YOUR VIEW.
I'M NOT ADJUSTING A CONSPIRACY.
I'M MERELY SAYING THAT WHEN YOU
LET ILLEGAL ALIENS USE THIS
CARD, WHICH WAS DESIGNED IN PART
FOR THEM, AND DON'T BE
DISINGENUOUS AND PRETEND
OTHERWISE, THAT WOULD BE A LIE,
AS YOU KNOW.
THE MAYOR BRAGGED ABOUT IT.
WHEN YOU LET THEM USE THIS CARD
TO REGISTER TO VOTE, BUT IN FACT
YOU ARE NOT REQUIRED TO SHOW
PROOF OF CITIZENSHIP TO REGISTER
IN ILLINOIS, YOU'RE WRONG.
YOU HAVE TO SAY THAT YOU'RE A
CITIZEN, YOU DON'T HAVE TO PROVE
IT.
YOU ARE ABETTING VOTER FRAUD AND
YOU KNOW THAT.
>> IS SIMPLY NOT TRUE.
I KNOW THE RULES TO BE A VOTER
REGISTRAR, THERE ARE LAWS IN
PLACE, AND FRANKLY, I JUST DON'T
FEEL LIKE IT MAKES SENSE TO TURN
COMMUNITIES, WE LIKE TO
CELEBRATE OUR NEIGHBORS.
WE LIKE TO SAY --
>> Tucker: IT'S NOT A QUESTION
OF CELEBRATING OUR NEIGHBORS.
YOU CAN CELEBRATE SOMEONE,
APPRECIATE THEM, TAKE THEM TO
DINNER, WHILE STILL
UNDERSTANDING THAT ONLY CITIZENS
ARE ALLOWED TO VOTE.
LET ME ASK MY QUESTION FOR A
THIRD TIME.
DO YOU THINK NONCITIZENS SHOULD
BE ALLOWED TO VOTE IN OUR
ELECTIONS?
>> THE FEDERAL LAW, STATE LAW
SAYS THAT ONLY CITIZENS CAN
VOTE.
I'M NOT GOING TO SAY AND PLAY A
GAME WHERE WE WILL DEMONIZE --
>> Tucker: IT'S NOT A GAME.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
THERE IS A FEDERAL LAW PASSED IN
1996, THE U.S. CODE, THAT SAYS
THAT NONCITIZENS CANNOT VOTE IN
FEDERAL ELECTIONS.
THEY WERE ALLOWED TO VOTE --
>> I BELIEVE IN FEDERAL LAW.
>> Tucker: YOU DON'T BELIEVE
IN FEDERAL LAW BECAUSE THIS CITY
CARD, THE I.D. THAT YOU MADE
POSSIBLE HIS EXPLICITLY DESIGNED
TO PREVENT FEDERAL IMMIGRATION
AUTHORITIES FROM ENFORCING
FEDERAL LAW.
OBVIOUSLY YOU DON'T BELIEVE IN
FEDERAL LAWS.
I JUST WANT TO KNOW WHAT YOU
THINK.
IF YOU COULD MAKE THE LAW, WOULD
YOU ALLOW, AS A THEORETICAL
MATTER, NONCITIZENS DEVOTE?
SPEAKER I MEAN, NO, OF COURSE
NOT.
WE HAVE LAWS UP ON THE BOOKS TO
MAKE SURE THAT CITIZENS CAN
VOTE.
I JUST DON'T BELIEVE IN
DEMONIZING UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS.
THAT IS NOT HOW I RUN MY OFFICE,
THIS IS NOT WHY I RAN FOR
OFFICE.
I'M A SON OF IMMIGRANTS.
AND WHEN I HEAR THIS KIND OF
RHETORIC --
>> Tucker: THAT'S IRRELEVANT.
YOU'RE A CITIZEN.
THE QUESTION IS NOT DO YOU LIKE
ALL PEOPLE HERE, THAT IS A
SEPARATE CATEGORY.
THE QUESTION IS, IS THERE A
MEANINGFUL DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A
CITIZEN AND NONCITIZEN?
YOU ARE TRYING TO ERASE THAT
DIFFERENCE.
SO WHAT WOULD BE THE DIFFERENCE
IS?
WHAT DO YOU THINK SHOULD BE THE
DIFFERENCE IS?
WHAT SHOULD CITIZENS GET THAT
NONCITIZENS DON'T?
>> THERE ARE LOTS OF
NONCITIZENS, BY THE WAY, WHO PAY
TAXES.
THERE ARE LOTS OF NONCITIZENS,
UNDOCUMENTED NEIGHBORS, WHO
SERVE IN THE ARMY.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE TRYING TO
BYPASS MY QUESTION.
THIS IS NOT A REFERENDUM AS TO
WHETHER THEY ARE NICE PEOPLE.
>> SOME HAVE GIVEN THEIR LIVES.
>> Tucker: THAT IS TRUE.
I'M ASKING YOU A MUCH DEEPER
QUESTION, AND YOU MAY NOT GET
THIS ON YOUR POLITICAL LIFE
OFTEN, BUT HAS TO DO WITH
CITIZENSHIP, THE FOUNDATION OF
THE COUNTRY.
WHAT IS THE DISTINCTION BETWEEN
CITIZENS AND NONCITIZENS?
WHAT DO CITIZENS GET THAT
NONCITIZENS DON'T?
WHY IS THAT A MEANINGFUL
DISTINCTION?
>> CITIZENS HAVE ACCESS TO A
SOCIAL SECURITY CARD, AND SOME
HAVE ACCESS TO THE SOCIAL SAFETY
NET.
IN THOSE DISTINCTIONS HAVE
ALWAYS BEEN IN PLACE, WHICH IS
WHY PEOPLE WORK SO HARD TO COME
HERE TO BECOME A PART OF OUR
AMERICAN FABRIC.
IT'S WHY MY PARENTS CAME HERE.
I JUST DON'T BELIEVE THAT THESE
DOG WHISTLES -- I'M NOT
SUGGESTING YOU ARE MAKING
THEM -- BUT I AM SAYING THAT
PEOPLE AROUND THE COUNTRY --
>> Tucker: WHAT DO YOU MEAN BY
DOG WHISTLES?
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
>> WHAT I MEAN BY DOG WHISTLE IS
THAT THERE SEEMS TO BE A
NATIONAL RHETORIC TO PIT FOR
READ PEOPLE AGAINST POOR BLACK
AND BROWN PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: I KNOW YOU HAVE A
HISTORY OF RACE BAITING, SO I'M
NOT SURPRISED YOU DID THAT.
I JUST WANT TO ASK YOU, LET'S BE
REAL, THIS IS CHICAGO.
CHICAGO IS NOT A CITY WHERE
ANYBODY IS TRYING TO WIN A LOT
OF POOR WHITE VOTERS.
AFRICAN-AMERICAN VOTERS ARE
DISSATISFIED WITH THE MAYOR.
AND EVERYONE I KNOW WHO COVERS
CHICAGO POLITICS SAYS, THIS IS
AN EFFORT TO BASICALLY IGNORE
THEM IN FAVOR OF A NEW CLASS OF
VOTERS, SOME OF THEM
NONCITIZENS.
IT'S NOT ABOUT WHITES ON ANY
LEVEL.
>> THAT'S NOT TRUE.
THERE IS NO GRAND CONSPIRACY
BETWEEN CHICAGO ELECTED
OFFICIALS AND THE MAYOR'S
OFFICE, THE BOARD OF ELECTIONS,
AND PEOPLE IN THIS CITY, TO SAY,
LET'S DEFRAUD THE ELECTORAL
PROCESS.
>> Tucker: WHAT IS THE CITY --
THIS IS THE ACTUAL FOREIGN
INTERFERENCE IN OUR ELECTIONS,
THE IDEA THAT FOREIGNERS COULD
BE VOTING.
YOU ARE DOING A LOT FOR ILLEGAL
ALIENS IN YOUR CITY.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING TO PREVENT
THEM FROM VOTING AND ELECTIONS?
>> LET'S BE CLEAR.
THERE IS ONE, EVIDENCE THAT THE
RUSSIAN FOREIGN INFLUENCE
MEDDLED IN OUR ELECTION.
>> Tucker: FOREIGNERS ARE
VOTING IN OUR ELECTIONS.
WERE YOU DOING ABOUT IT, IF YOU
CARE ABOUT FOREIGN INTERFERENCE?
>> I WANT TO KNOW WHY DID THE
COMMISSION WAS DISBANDED BECAUSE
THEY WERE LOOKING FOR ALL THE
INFORMATION --
>> Tucker: WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
YOU JUST GAVE AN I.D. CARD TO
PEOPLE HERE ILLEGALLY IN
VIOLATION OF OUR LAWS AND YOU
ARE LETTING THEM USE THAT CARD
TO REGISTER TO VOTE.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
>> MY FAMILY WILL HAVE THAT I.D.
CARD AND WE WILL USE IT TO CHECK
OUT BOOKS AT THE LIBRARY, JUST
LIKE SOMEONE ELSE WILL.
I WILL USE IT TO GET ON A TRAIN.
THIS IS A HIM A USABLE I.D.